every four seconds someone is diagnosed
with Alzheimer's disease it's the most
common cause of dementia affecting over
40 million people worldwide and yet
finding a cure is something that still
eludes researchers today dr. a Louis
Alzheimer
a German psychiatrist first described
the symptoms in 1901 when he noticed
that a particular Hospital patient had
some peculiar problems including
difficulty sleeping disturbed memory
drastic mood changes and increasing
confusion when the patient passed away
Alzheimer was able to do an autopsy and
test his idea that perhaps her symptoms
were caused by irregularities in the
brain structure what he found beneath
the microscope were visible differences
in brain tissue in the form of misfolded
proteins called plaques and
neurofibrillary tangles those plaques
and tangles work together to break down
the brain structure plaques arise when
another protein in the fatty membranes
surrounding nerve cells gets sliced up
by a particular enzyme resulting in beta
amyloid proteins which are sticky and
have a tendency to clump together that
clumping is what forms the things we
know as plaques these clumps block
signaling and therefore communication
between cells and also seem to trigger
immune reactions that cause the
destruction of disabled nerve cells in
Alzheimer's disease neurofibrillary
tangles are built from a protein known
as tau the brains nerve cells contain a
network of tubes that act like a highway
for food molecules among other things
usually the tau protein ensures that
these tubes are straight allowing
molecules to pass through freely but in
Alzheimer's disease the protein
collapses into twisted strands or
tangles making the tubes disintegrate
obstructing nutrients from reaching the
nerve cell and leading to cell death
the destructive pairing of plaques and
tangles starts in a region called the
hippocampus which is responsible for
forming memories that's why a short-term
memory loss is usually the first symptom
of Alzheimer's the proteins then
progressively invade other parts of the
brain creating unique changes that
signal various stages of the disease at
the front of the brain the proteins
destroy the ability to process logical
thoughts next they shift to the region
that controls emotions resulting in
erratic mood changes at the top of the
brain they cause paranoia and
hallucinations and once they reach the
brains rear the plaques and tangles work
together to erase the minds deepest
memories eventually the control centers
governing heart rate and breathing are
overpowered as well resulting in death
the immensely destructive nature of this
disease has inspired many researchers to
look for a cure but currently they're
focused on slowing its progression one
temporary treatment helps reduce the
breakdown of acetylcholine an important
chemical messenger in the brain which is
decreased in Alzheimer's patients due to
the death of the nerve cells that make
it another possible solution is a
vaccine that trains the body's immune
system to attack beta amyloid plaques
before they can form clumps but we still
need to find an actual cure Alzheimer's
disease was discovered more than a
century ago and yet still it is not well
understood perhaps one day we'll grasp
the exact mechanisms at work behind this
threat and a solution will be unearthed
you